it's a rainy october day here in the
hudson valley in new york
and we just had tornado weather a little
bit earlier today
this is actually one of my favorite
times of year where it's fairly cool the
leaves are turning and they should be
spectacular
and since it's october that means that
it's actually time for me to do my my
channel update for the month where i
talk about
some of the things that i was doing or
finding out about or
considering during september and then
give up some previews about what's
coming up for this this current month of
october as usual i'm a little bit late
we're already in the behind end of the
first week of uh october but
well maybe with time we'll we'll start
catching up and doing these on the first
of the month
so
september a lot of a lot of stuff going
on in september that's part of how i got
behind
one of the things that's been taking up
a lot of time has been preparation for
class because
what i do with my classes that i teach
for marist is i use the course
management system to create an entire
online learning environment for my
students so that they're
they're not just learning when they're
in
the class sessions or when they're
reading on their own
but they've got a lot of lesson
materials i don't use actual textbooks i
create sort of like a virtual textbook
with lesson sections on each reading
that we do each you know class session
prepping for that and lots of resources
which have to be curated and found on
the net
i record the lecture videos as you know
because you've probably seen some of
them those have to go into the the
course management system
and then i i do all the assignments and
i i assign a lot of assignments short
writing
pieces
at least weekly sometimes bi-weekly
bi-weekly twice weekly for my my
students
so there's a lot of
a lot of maintenance that that takes and
a lot of producing new material that
eventually i'll probably turn into some
some website i
also i also create a lot of handouts
and since i'm usually teaching some new
material each semester for instance the
intro class is all new texts all things
that i haven't taught
at marist before and the ethics is a few
new things i'm always adding some new
handouts
and i upload those
into my academia.edu
site so that they're publicly available
for for other people who'd like to use
them as teaching documents
so that's been taking a lot of time i've
also been doing quite a bit with some
online learning platforms
that are not connected with marist at
all they're not connected with any
public or private universities or
colleges but these are sort of
standalone
posing themselves as the future of
education kind of sites one of these is
learnest and i have been developing what
i call mini courses where i have a few
lecture videos and maybe some of the
core concept videos and then some
handouts
um
some links to where they can find
whatever text it is that i'm you know
focused on i've got some on cicero and
plato and bentham and kant so far where
they can find these texts online
and then you know links to encyclopedia
articles or other good websites that
talk about those so i've been starting
in september i've been pretty good about
this trying to get
one mini course
put into learners each each week usually
doing doing those on the weekends
because they take about a good three
four hours to put together
but then they're out there and people
who are lifelong learners
can find them
and progress through them at their own
pace i'm also going to be working with
curious um
i
now have access to the lesson builder
curious is now going much more live than
they were before they they used one of
my older videos to create some lessons
on john paul sartre and this month i'm
going to start creating lessons on plato
starting with the apology and then then
we'll see where we go from there i don't
want to necessarily tie my my hands too
much with saying i'm going to do exactly
this this and this but we're going to
start with the apology
and curious is kind of cool because what
it does is it lets you
upload the
the videos and then you can have
questions that a student has to answer
put in multiple choice form
and
you can upload you know handouts or or
other you know lesson materials that
you'd have with it some of them are
going to be free some of them are going
to be
not free charging a fairly minimal cost
for for access to the lesson
um so i'm gonna be you know filming some
new videos where i go a bit more into
depth on on you know for example plato's
apology
and uh tie it in with with stuff so it's
it's a richer learning experience that
it makes possible i've also been talking
with some other
platforms um
about doing work with them some of what
i've been doing is actually giving them
advice about how they could could
situate themselves
uh because i'm involved with this this
sort of new world of online learning
you know that's distinct from the mooc
stuff over there this is more for the
the people who are looking for
more individuated um
and
at their own pace kind of thing not in
some you know massive thing over there
that's only the
you know elite institutions but but
um this is a little bit more
entrepreneurial i kind of like this a
bit more
so i'm i'm looking at doing some work
with them but i don't think that's going
to be doing i don't think i'm going to
be doing a lot more stuff this month
with with them just probably with
curious and learners
um
what else i've started blogging more
actively again i had let my blogs
sort of uh just hang out there with lots
of entries on on i have four main blogs
at this point which is
in a lot of ways kind of excessive i
have rex's dna which is the first blog
that i started a long time ago
that's my main blog and and i realized
that instead of just writing
you know longer articles on it i could
also use it as sort of an updates blog
as people um get to know me and want to
know what's going on with me
so i've been doing that with it
and i haven't put as many entries as i'd
like but i just published one today on
cont and violence and this you know
incident that i shot a video on that i
think everybody's familiar with by now
with the two guys and rastafan don who
uh got into a fist fight one of the one
of whom shot the other one with rubber
bullets over some matter and con
interpretation
so i've been writing for a system new
etiquette i've been doing some things
with the saddlers existentialism updates
which is a blog that i'm using basically
to house materials that i'm going to
turn into some courses on
existentialist thought which will be
available online for interested learners
as i get the stuff
moving
um
virtue ethics digest
that i i hadn't published anything in
since march which is for me kind of
you know i i'm a bit of a not not only a
perfectionist but a person who feels
guilty about starting things and then
not getting them
all the way through so it felt good to
get an uh get a blog entry out on virtue
ethics digest
this last week
and i started this new blog heavy metal
philosopher
and i've been writing things in there
not as frequently as i'd like but
every so often i've got four entries and
i'm working on a fifth and sixth entry
right now
so
that's kind of good i i enjoy blogging
and
something that i started out doing
before i was shooting any of these
videos
and
i want to get back into doing more of
that i'm also clearing more space for
doing
more strictly academic writing i've been
working on a paper for a conference that
is coming up this month
and you know writing a bit of of stuff
here and there on on
other topics in aristotle and some
um for the book projects that i'm
working on
now what else did i do i i had a talk at
the culinary institute of america as
part of their feasting and foraging day
and i talked about
symposia and how they started out as
drinking parties and what we know about
them and how they got to be the
drier dollar academic affairs that we
have today
and
uh we we actually it wasn't quite a
symposium
um but we did at least get to have some
some hard apple cider during and it was
kind of fun to to do that out in the
open uh had some good q a and there's a
video of it which which you may have
seen by now
i went to a conference at bard college
the
failing fast the educated citizen in
crisis conference which was pretty good
hosted by the honor rent center
that stuff is all available online so i
don't really need to summarize it for
you i'm going to be writing a bit about
one of the topics that kept coming up
about privatization of education
and
why i think that we need to be really
careful in using that term because it
means different things i'll be writing
about that in a rexus dna tk this month
videos i have been shooting quite a few
videos of course i've been shooting them
in my courses
the intro class
we
finished up with plato
and moved into aristotle i shot through
three videos on aristotle one on on some
topics in the metaphysics and two on
the nick of mccain ethics
and i've been shooting some other videos
in my
ethics class i shot one on republic book
nine you know full lecture video
and i have been shooting a few other
well you know the core concept videos
the shorter videos in my ethics classes
i've been posting a lot of bentham ones
lately since i shot a lot of bentham
footage
um
i got one more of the 10 shorts videos
out
so that was good
and i shot a video on that contemporary
event that involved philosophy with
the guys who got into the fist fight
about about kant and i that's a new
series for me that i'm gonna i'm gonna
start doing
so what's going on for october what have
i got coming up
i'm giving a paper this coming weekend
at fordham university in the society for
ancient greek philosophy which is
coinciding with with some other
learned societies i'm going to be
talking i'm not actually going to read
the whole paper which i have posted
online
uh in my
academia.edu profile if you're
interested in reading it so it's a rough
draft still at this point needs a lot of
secondary lit references that are that
are you know
germane to the topic and there's a lot
of aristotle passages that i'm going to
be
also adding to to it because he he talks
about the the topics that i'm focused on
throughout his work what are those
topics
anger
justice and injustice
if you've looked at my aristotle videos
you know that i'm i'm working on a book
on aristotle and anger and anger is
particularly interesting because it ties
in with our conceptions of justice and
injustice in very complex ways for
aristotle so that's what i'll be talking
about there
and i'm hoping to to meet up with a few
colleagues and make some new contacts
and perhaps make some new
friends here's some good papers i'm also
cheering at least one
of the panels perhaps two
um
you know when when you're an academic
that's one of the duties that you have
when you go to conferences quite often
especially as you get a bit older and
more established you chair panels in
part to keep people on time because
otherwise people just keep talking and
talking so the chair is the person who
introduces everybody and then says all
right you got 25 minutes
now you're done talking now we listen to
this guy over here or this this you know
woman over here
so that's that's one thing going on
coming up towards the very end of the
month i am doing a brown bag lunch with
some students
in marist college's uh medieval and
renaissance studies program
and the topic that i'm going to be
talking about
is one that i've been doing research on
for quite a while
namely the seven deadly sins which
didn't start out as the seven deadly
sins they started out as the eight
principal vices
talked about by the monastic desert
fathers and then gradually as they
filter into uh you know the middle ages
through through gregory the great
his morali on job and some of the other
interesting literature
they become the seven deadly sins and so
the question is how do we go from eight
to seven did we drop something out and
there's some interesting transformations
along the way um i have to pack all that
into about a
half an hour maybe 45 minutes tops talk
so that's going to be kind of a tall
order to do
i might be doing some some more radio
shows i i don't know you know the
calendar is a little bit hazy at this
point about that if not in october
definitely in november
i'm going to be doing a lot more
blogging i'm trying to get you know
get back on track with with doing some
more of that kind of writing which i
very much enjoy but which is fairly time
consuming i want my goal and this is
pretty ambitious
is to make sure that i i write in
arrexis di noetique
sadler's existentialism updates
um
virtue ethics digest and heavy metal
philosopher
at least two times two blog entries for
each of those
is this coming month
um i guess i can count the arrexis to
you know idk one that i just finished on
on content violence
in there but you know i wanna i wanna
get these back on track because i feel
they're sort of like abandoned children
in a way i've been shooting so much
video stuff that it takes me away from
from that
i'll be doing more courses on learners
like i said and
adding some lessons in curious
and i'm exploring a few other things
people are contacting me now
i think largely in part because of these
philosophy videos that i shoot
asking me if i want to be involved in
other new projects which involve
you know video conferencing or courses
or or little lessons here and there so
that's kind of nice
i'll be posting more and more course
material as i develop them you know for
example the handouts i'm working on a
handout right now on epicurus on on
friendship and after i get that finished
i've got to do some stuff on aristotle
and pleasures
cicero on friendship um you know
jon stewart mill on various topics like
you know does can utilitarianism
actually admit of justice or talk about
virtue so lots of interesting stuff like
that coming up
um now as far as the videos go strictly
videos youtube stuff
what i want to do during this month
is continue with the chest off videos in
the existentialism series there's a lot
to be said about this guy live chest off
and for the most for the most part i'm
going to be working on stuff in his
early works
that might actually carry me through
into november i don't know
if i if i finish up with the chest off
early enough
then i may start shooting on
gabriel marcel or i might go back and
start shooting some stuff on
on real quick or maybe shooting some
more nature or kicker guard i don't
really know quite at this point i'm
sticking with the chest off
i need to actually
get finished
with something i started a while back
and then then you know didn't see all
the way through and that's the videos on
aristotle's categories that's a text
that gets used in a lot of classes and
it's very confusing at first
and
i it is also very important for for
understanding aristotle's metaphysics
and his theory of language and how
language connects up with reality and
thought
so i want to
plow through those and shoot those in
our home studio
um there's going to be a lot of new
class videos coming up in the intro
class
we're going to be talking about epicurus
on on love and friendship we're going to
be talking about cicero
uh st augustine and
i think towards the end of the month we
may also get to
the love letters between abelard and
eloise i don't think we'll get to thomas
aquinas i think that's coming up in
november um i i'm not quite sure about
exactly where the cutoffs are where the
dates are so that's what's going on in
the intro class
the ethics class
i'm going to be shooting more core
concept videos and uploading them i've
got some some rand videos that that need
to come out just a few of those more
bentham videos core concept videos
we're going to have some some epictetus
ones some ross wd ross the guy you know
the right and the good
uh and then maybe some more [ __ ] videos
i'm not quite sure if i'm gonna do those
and i would like to get shot some more
aristotle core concept videos about the
virtues and vices because i've got a
project that i want to do with those
so that's quite a bit i don't know if
i'm going to shoot any of the more or
put together any more of the 10 view
short videos this month if i don't do
that it'll happen in november
i'm not sure if i'm going to do any more
philosophy and contemporary events
videos although i'd really love to get
into that i don't know if i'm going to
do any more philosophical you know
development stuff about you know how
how
i got into this guy or got into this guy
in part because i'm just making so many
other videos at this time
um so
if i get any of that other stuff done
that's gravy that's icing on the cake
but what what i'm really going to be
concentrating on this month is the
existentialism chest off videos the
aristotle categories videos the course
videos from my intro class on love
friendship and desire and all those core
concept videos that that i just keep you
know churning out
we've passed the 75 mark this month for
core concept videos which is kind of
cool you know
more than 75
short focused videos on particular
topics in philosophy it's been been a
long long road and
it's kind of cool to get that far we
passed you know i think the 35 mark for
the existentialism videos there's about
another 65 more of those to go
um
yeah there's there's a lot of cool
milestones coming up so that's what's
what's going on in october provided
everything stays on track
you notice i'm not talking much about
like my knee
really i should be doing physical
therapy at this point but i i just wear
this knee brace and and get around and
it's okay i really need to to to start
spending a bit more time on the non-job
non-philosophy areas of my life so i can
get those get those sort of things on
track because um there's really no
excuse for
for
not getting into the physical therapy
that's going to be required for the
surgery eventually down the line
um i am able to get around fairly well
i don't have to you know use a crutch
anymore it gets sore after a while
weather changing actually weirdly
affects it but but on the whole things
are things are pretty good
i would like to clear some more time and
space for doing some some pure pleasure
reading but i don't foresee that coming
up in the month of october
the only other thing that that is on the
horizon that could be of interest
and i'll close with this
is
if my wife
and i actually follow through
on a plan that she has about halloween
and halloween costumes i may be losing
the beard
um
because that would be required for the
sort of costume that that we'd be
wearing
and
i'll let you in on what it is she wants
to go as the blues brothers i think it's
a great idea
but um there's no way i can there's no
way i can have this fortunately my beard
grows back pretty quick after i do
shave it'll be a little weird if we do
that because
i haven't cut this off i've trimmed it
but i haven't cut it off for
over a year so you get kind of
accustomed to it
so that's what's going on with me that's
the month of october that's the you know
summary of what took place in in
september
there you go i'll try to put links for
uh some of these things in case you're
interested in them and you want to click
on them
and i'll
shoot another video like this
in november